-I also want to ask what you --
You know,
because it's our 1,000th show --
Oh, that's beautiful.
That's a beautiful dress.
Can you tell me, is that --
did you -- have you worn --
Where have you worn that?
-This was from when
you hosted the "Golden Globes."
-Oh.
-Yay!
-Oh, it's so beautiful.
How many more gowns do you have
since you and I met?
-I am not out, Seth.
I have plenty.
I have some I haven't worn yet.
[ Both laugh ]
I just love them.
-What do you miss the most --
What do you miss the most
about the office?
-About the office?
Being with all of our
goofy friends.
-Yeah.
-I miss these people.
They're fun.
And we have little game nights.
-There are also nights where you
will make margaritas
for everybody.
-Oh, yeah.
That's my favorite thing
to do at the office
is make office margaritas.
-And can you tell everybody
who's watching at home
why I'm unable join you
for office margaritas?
-Because office
margaritas happen
during the taping of
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
[ Both laugh ]
-Just once it would be nice if
you waited until I was done!
And by the way, I come back and
there's -- nobody's there.
Just a bunch
of lime juice on desks.
-[ Laughs ]
-Disgusting.
-It's a sticky place
to write, Seth.
-[ Laughs ]
It is a sticky place to write.
What do you miss least?
-The thing I miss least is the
access to a butt-ton of food.
-Oh, interesting.
-It's pretty wild.
I am not kidding when I say
I have lost 10 pounds...
-Yeah.
-...by being at home.
-I think, for me, the --
I bet the biggest drop for me
the last three months
is just an intake of sodium.
Because I eat so many -- like,
I'll just, like, get stressed --
like, have writing stress
and just go eat
a handful of pretzels.
-Yeah.
-And, uh...yeah.
So, you're right.
I didn't think about that,
but that's a really nice --
nice part of this.
-Yeah.
I can't wait to go back there,
balloon up, break out.
-[ Laughs ]
-I can't wait.
-Amber, can you believe
it's been 1,000 shows?
-I can't believe
it's been 1,000 shows.
Congratulations, Seth!
-And to you, Amber.
It was all -- all the better
for having you with us.
And, oh!
This is really exciting.
-What?
-I can't believe
I almost forgot this.
Because a lot of people
have been tweeting at me
that I should give you my show,
because they are so enamored
with you and less so with me.
And that's fair.
But you do --
You are gonna be doing a show
on Peacock,
the new NBC streaming service.
-"The Amber Ruffin Show."
-Yeah.
-It's coming to you.
And it's gonna happen.
When? Well, we've hit a hitch,
haven't we?
But as soon as things clear out,
we're coming to get you guys.
-And that's so exciting.
And it should be noted
that's something --
I do want to give credit
to the network because
this is something
that's been in the works
for almost a year now.
And they wisely
recognized your talent,
and I'm so excited for that --
that chapter for you, as well.
Thank you for spending
this chapter with us.
I love you so much,
and I will see you soon.
-I love you more!
-[ Laughs ]
-Happy 1,000!
-Do you love me more
than Anderson?
-Yes!
-Oh, thank you.
[ Laughs ]